c'est mes amis bombe à ses partisans à
faire la petite vidéo snap lips ma chère
tamara mâché elle mais qui fait des
grandes questions quel est ton plat
préféré
pas mal pas mal pas mal pas mal mais ce
sera à n'importe quoi tout le loin si tu
devais te retrouver seul sur une île
sans rien ni personne n'est que tu peux
amener juste une chose ce serait quoi
ouais j'aime bien j'aime beaucoup me
what une pistache qui va pas vivre
longtemps sur une figure toi que j'ai je
connais des gens qui ont fait koh lanta
qui ont trouvé une pistache et qui s'en
sortent très d'accord tamara dgo c'est
quoi ton numéro de téléphone alors celle
des caisses qui sont avérées crise
pourquoi pensez toujours les corps je
réponds toujours les commandes de
l'édition ok next elle vous a nommé la
même attention à quoi et tu accroc
pistage
il se dit prêt si le grand dossier
c'est vrai ça je vais jamais dit c'est
vrai qu'en coulisse il reste tout le
temps la réal à la jimmy waite ou
chevaleyre j'adore sa paire de demis ch
tamara la partie de ton corps que tu
préfères ah bon c'est comme ça toi ne
mallegol pas le nom a su immédiatement à
quoi ressemblait ta copine au lycée
alors moi j'ai déjà dire voilà on avait
70 ans jeanne avait 70 tout simplement
chacun fait comme il y en a qui l'ont 1
2 je suis pas lire et 70 n ont plus
agressif ton plus grand secret tamara lé
talent vient surtout la bouche on en
fait
mon plus grand secret tu n'as même pas
de cliquer sur le 5 nov
non non il ya un moment si tu as non non
je pose une autre question non je pose
une autre question est ce que tu te
trouves que cette interview est
pertinente
ça veut dire que c'est un truc léger qui
s'envole et qu'en même temps que les
quais jolie plein de couleurs qui est
gros mais toujours une touche de
légèreté
puisque ça s'envole de quoi as tu peur
ouais j'ai peur des hamsters exactement
comme les éléphants j'ai peur que ça
rentre dans ma compliqué tu l'as compris
c'est bon j'ai peur que ça rentre dans
ma trompe
j'assume pas dit thomas van on met
d'accord et est pas mal le dernier pays
que tu as visité argumente t aller en
free et madame si oui ou non il est allé
en est l'une est alors c'était bien
c'était c'était frisé frérot c'est pas
de bisou parce que déjà premièrement il
connaît pas deuxième en six mois ça ils
te gifle eu divers faux je suis
absolument pas coupable de ce qui vient
de se passer on est d'accord et mais
elle s'excuse par donc j'espère qu'elle
serait la réincarnation oba simple
facile hyper simple tu m'as tu m'avais
revient au budget
messieurs ouais ouais ça ça va leur est
pas un texto la détente acquitté crie
c'est qui c'est ce qu'il ya dans mon
jardin sa patte à temps mais c'est plus
beit de savoir ce qui est écrit on peut
savoir pourquoi c'est important
ah on y revient c'est si important que
[ __ ] tu m'avais pas dit et alors vous
dites quoi d'accord vous parlez chocolat
ensemble et c'est quoi tes préféré aller
mon chéri à l'alcool je vois je vois moi
j'aime pas du tout un d'antenne ya
l'alcool tamarins non la lnd nyan comme
ça mais qui dit oui des yeux qui piquent
rouge qui pique
c'est pour ryan ça et je trouve à pas
mal et donc toi qu'est ce que tu fais
tous les soirs tu un petit singe chez le
petit ça ouais je m'accroche de partout
je lui annonçais voilà je monte dans mon
lit comme dans un arbre mais dis moi tu
as marre en parement d'arbres tu m'as
pas dit que tu étais sorti avec un gland
du coup qu'elle adopte t suffisait à
rester aussi que van damme se délite ça
c'est un bon mélange bon mais là on est
en fait c'est tous mes potes et
l'acquitté cris
elle a dit tous les mots qu'est la vente
est hélas en avait dix ans explique nous
explique nous approfondie lépine je
parle plus avec sa maman 80 saloperie
c'est le prix là ça marche vraiment bien
dire et ses trois petits c'est à toi
même couleur de cheveux même bas du
visage c'était toi
c'est quand à faire un jeu je prochain
mais qui reste rien pour ça mais si la
presle et pour moi cela va bloquer messi
ça va il pas mal quand même
mouais mouais ça je prends son papa le
choix ok vous est à toi - pas bonjour
anne genre s'appelle pas pourquoi c'est
pourquoi je sors principal en plus tu as
de la chance il a l'air d'avoir une
bonne haleine de chacal marrant
attendu mais ce pionner depuis tout à
l'heure
bah non plus dans ma chambre c'est tout
donc je t'aime ou pas bah quoi badra
guide et vous mais tu sais que tu
connais avec toi bats plein de trucs
regarde 5 trucs pour draguer remake mais
c'est des conneries ça ça marche pas ah
bon tu as déjà ici
ouais
bon on a onze alors comment waouh
36 oh non c'est tout grain de base à des
kilos sa cote et wau 91
hahaha
tu fais ta mine et 5 heures du matin
au matin
il a réussi
oui
costa la série cours à d'abord être que
c'est bas
cadets 1 pas du tout tam n'y a aucune
raison pour que les autres notamment
chez ceux qui se moquent sont souvent
ceux qui sont les plus à plaindre
là c'est bon je suis grosse pas divine
et la meilleure table et rendent alors à
la rentrée des classes soient respectés
c'est mal notre s'ajoute le prochain et
qui rentre il est pour moi
des quotas par attentes
je ne fais tout le temps dès qu'un mec
me regarde plus de deux secondes c'est
important d'avoir une étiquette grosse
sur le fond dit go c'est pareil pour moi
c'est très joli
toi tu sais que le jeu c'est évident
mais c'est un garçon sébastien tamara
les garçons ça n'intéresse pas tiens
salut que bute au focus qui as tu veux
pas contre diego comment tu plonges fois
que tu montes que david ma vieille que
tu as plein de trucs dans le bide au
laos
on recommence
je crois qu'un gars ont compris tout
mahmoud génifique monde tu vas pas
sortir comme ça sympa non
halloween c'est la fête des mains pas
des prostitués masculins merci ça fait
deux heures jet set a ressemblé amy
winehouse quoi il constitue et je savais
pas qui était drôle ont battu les ânes
défoncé qui fait que des communes ce
moment tout ce qui t'arrive de la
famille rld et brandit le monde après
tout ça sont importés choix dans les
vacances stock l'a dit c'est mort pour
moi changement de stratégie et zag à
dire edel au cinéma avec moi demande
pourquoi pas l'a320 et l'a321
certes il faut que je paye bauer tu veux
pas vous mais qu en qui j'ai pas trop
les copains s'en sortent en balayant les
filles en sol et quand même avec
toilettes